what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime uproar and today i will be talking
about yet another
jaw dropping installment in the boku no
hero story we just learned more about
deku's newest quirk and this quirk
seems to be a lot more powerful than it
might have seemed at first
in fact it apparently has the ability to
enhance the power of one for all itself
while limiting the damage to deku's body
which is a huge
development oh and i'm also low-key
angry at horikoshi right now and i will
explain why so let's get into it
if you enjoyed the boku no pico content
on this channel and you want to see more
leave a like and comment it only takes a
second but it helps a lot
and if you're new to anime out pro or
maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications finally this video
will of course contain boku no hero
manga spoilers so please proceed with
caution
you have been warned yes i know that i
said boku no pico earlier
instead of boku no hero i did it on
purpose just to see how many of you
would start commenting about it
right away also i'm not really angry at
horikoshi he can do whatever he wants
with his story and i love where the
story has been heading for several arcs
now
but did he really have to gravely injure
both my number one hero waifu miruko
and my number one villain waifu lady
nagant and don't get me started on
midnight
this is not cool our mha milfs are in
danger
anyway the latest chapter starts off
with a flashback in which lady nagant
and overhaul are preparing for the
mission to capture
deku overhaul explains that he knows
deku because deku was the one who ruined
his plan
and this means that overhaul will be
able to positively identify the target
for
lady nagant once they meet him face to
face so lady nagant decides to bring
overhaul with her on the mission
since he could confirm that they have
the right target
overhaul agrees but he has one condition
and can you guess
what that condition is yes it's free
tickets to my chemical romance no the
condition is of course that after the
mission is complete
overhaul gets to see his boss again man
you'd really think that a guy who loves
and respects his boss so much would have
thought twice before brutally torturing
the boss's granddaughter but what do i
know
back in the present overhaul is on the
roof of the building and yelling like a
madman like
seriously he does seem to be out of his
mind he says that he has kept up his
part of the deal he identified deku as
the target
so now lady nagant has to honor her part
of the deal and let him see the boss
but lady nagan's plan is to distract
deku by turning her gun
on overhaul himself if deku really is
the pure-hearted hero that he claims to
be
then he will try to save overhaul's life
despite the fact that overhaul
is a horrible person and a murderous
villain if deku
takes the bait and tries to save
overhaul lady nagant will be able to use
that moment of distraction to take him
down
in order to reach overhaul all the way
on the top of the building lady nagant
increases the size of her
arm rifle until it becomes a freaking
cannon i have to say the lady nagan's
quirk just keeps getting cooler the more
we learn about it
and i really think that this quirk has
some amazing long range capabilities
that we haven't even seen yet
and that could come into play later on
in the story i mean if lady nagant
is still alive but more on that later as
she fires off her new hand cannon and
the giant bullet flies towards
overhaul deku springs into action first
he uses black whip to push himself off
and gain momentum
and then he uses fujin yet again we are
told that
fajin works by storing the kinetic
energy created by repeating regular
motions
and deku then uses fajin in combination
with one for all at 45 percent to mimic
the movements of
all might movements that make deku even
faster than lady nagan's bullet
as the bullet flies towards overhaul
deku rushes up to him like an absolute
mad lad
and pushes him out of the way it seems
that in order to get there on time
deku used one for all at sudo 100
this means that using one for all in
combination with black whip and then
fajin
allowed deku to use power equivalent to
one for all
at one hundred percent without actually
using one for all at one hundred percent
and hurting his body in the process this
is a huge
deal and i'll talk more about this later
on in the video lady nagant is shocked
that deku was able to catch up to her
bullet although it seems that deku
anticipated what lady nagant was about
to do
so he actually started moving even
before the bullet was fired
after pushing overhaul out of harm's way
deku uses black whip to kind of
slingshot himself down from the roof and
back towards
lady nagant the vestige of the third
user reveals that before now
deku was switching between all for one
at 45 percent
danger sense smoke screen black whip
fajin and float
so he was using six different quirks in
rapid succession
and he was doing a great job and i have
to say that i'm extremely impressed with
how quickly deku has been able to learn
the different quirks and to use them
effectively together
but eventually deku just couldn't
process all of those quirks at the same
time
it was just too much especially for
someone who hasn't had the time to
master
each of these individual quirks deku
realizes that he can't handle using
all six of them at once and so he starts
using only three quirks
one for all itself black whip and fog in
and this combination of three quirks is
proving to be extremely effective
against a long-range fighter
like lady nagant lady nagant tries to
fall back
but deku manages to land a pseudo 100
manchester smash right into her rifle
so basically deku used fajin to make the
power of this manchester smash
equivalent to one for all at one hundred
percent even though he wasn't
technically at one hundred percent
deku manages to smash lady nagan's rifle
arm to pieces
and he tells her that it's over her
rifle arm is
done for in that moment lady nagant has
an
inner realization she realizes that deku
did not hesitate at all when it came to
risking his own life to save
overhaul even though deku knows that
overhaul is a villain who has done
truly terrible things to many people
including little arie
this kind of pure-hearted commitment to
heroism without any hesitation
reminds leading the gaunt of her younger
self back when she was brainwashed by
the hero public safety commission
into believing that she was making the
world a better place by carrying out
their orders
just like deku lady nagant was once an
idealistic hero who would do anything to
save people
she believed that she was making the
world a better place
her intentions were good she had a
strong moral compass she was a good
person
but she was being manipulated into doing
terrible things and eventually this
destroyed her on the inside as lady
nagand falls to the ground
deku reaches out and grabs her hand deku
reveals that the trajectory of the
bullet that lady nagon had fired at
overhaul was actually
off the bullet was never going to hit
him at all
lady nagant was bluffing in fact she
also had the chance to hit deku from
behind
as he rushed to help overhaul but she
didn't in her past
lady nagant was manipulated and betrayed
by the hero society so she turned
against it
but this doesn't make her a bad person
she still has a moral compass
and deku believes that she still has the
heart of a hero
he even invites lady nagan to fight
alongside the heroes and
against all for one lady nagan smiles
and just as she is about to say that
deku is a true hero
we see all for one laughing as he says
that hearts can be swayed easily which
is why he prepared for lady nagan's
potential
failure it seems that all for one has
secretly been watching this fight
all along and when he sees that lady
nagant is no longer sticking to the plan
he activates a massive explosion deku
screams out as lady nagan's severely
burnt body
falls to the ground all for once says
that in the end
lady nagant ended up just being a tool
first
a tool for the hero public safety
commission and now for him
i'm not sure where exactly all for one
is currently located but i'm sure it's
somewhere safe
because he wants to stay one step ahead
of the heroes so he's probably
monitoring the situation using one of
his quirks
then suddenly hawks swoops in and grabs
lady nagant just before she hits the
ground
hawks is seemingly able to use his wings
again at least for a few seconds at a
time but i'm not sure for how long he
can use them because they're definitely
not fully healed yet
hawks calls out to his senpai and tells
her not to die
and that is how this jaw dropping
chapter ends
lady nagant is hurt and she is hurt
bad and to make things worse it happened
just as she was undergoing some pretty
major character development and becoming
an even more
interesting character than she already
was and she's obviously waifu so
horikoshi bro
i need you to stop hurting the waifus
now i think that hawks showing up and
saving lady nagant means that she
probably won't
die but she's definitely severely
injured so she'll probably be out of
commission for a while
unless her quirk has more secret
properties that we don't know about like
the ability to heal her flesh
she will probably spend the rest of this
arc in a hospital to be fair
her quirk does involve manipulating
flesh so maybe she does have some type
of regeneration ability i kind of hope
that she does have some ability to
regenerate
because i want to see her in action
again soon but we'll have to wait and
see
by the way how freaking ruthless is all
for one
this man shows no mercy to anyone not
even a waifu like lady nagant
oh and how did he make her explode in
the first place
was it a physical explosive device that
he somehow managed to attach to her
or was it some sort of explosive quirk
that he snuck inside her
back when he gave her airwalk or was it
something else
altogether from the way the panels were
drawn it definitely looked like she
exploded as the result of some kind of
quirk
it almost looked like she used
self-destruct from pokemon
my guess is that all for one either
threw in an extra explosive quirk inside
her
when he gave her airwalk a quirk that he
could remotely detonate somehow
or that he used some kind of explosive
quirk on her without her knowledge a
quirk that allows for the remote
activation of an explosion at some point
in the future
to be honest this was a cool twist it
fits perfectly with all for one's
character
and i actually loved it and i loved the
chapter as a whole but at the same time
i really hope that lady nagant
pulls through i've been loving her
character and i really liked how this
chapter fleshed it out
even more and even though lady nagant
has not had a lot of screen time
she's already become such an interesting
character at first she was just some
villain waifu at tartarus with an
attitude
then we realized that she was actually a
former hero who betrayed the hero
society and who was so strong that hawks
told deku to run if he ever sees her
then we learned her tragic backstory a
backstory that exposed the terrifying
dark side
of the hero society and after that we
understood why she ultimately turned
against
the hero society but now thanks to this
chapter
we know that there is still hope for
redemption lady nagant
still has a strong moral compass even
though she is technically a villain
assassin
she wasn't really going to kill overhaul
and she chose not to shoot deku in the
back
even though she could have she may not
like the hero society
but that society is now in ruins anyway
so why not
join up with the heroes who are
pure-hearted like dekku deku and the
others are no longer fighting for the
corrupt hero society
they are not serving the interests of
the public safety commission
they're just fighting to protect the
innocent and bring all of this chaos
under control like i said i loved this
chapter
i loved lady nagan's character
development and the twist at the end
with the explosion was so good but also
heartbreaking at the same time
definitely let me know what you guys
thought of the chapter and do you like
lady nagan's character as much as i do
okay now let's talk about fajin and its
crazy potential
even though this quirk involves
releasing sudden bursts of energy
it's not a one and done type deal deku
can apparently store kinetic energy
in different parts of his body and then
unleash them at the right moment
and even more importantly this quirk
allows deku to use the equivalent of 100
of one for all's power without damaging
his body
this is like the perfect quirk for deku
and you could just imagine all of the
attack
combos that we're gonna be seeing in the
future as a result of
bhajin the pseudo 100 manchester smash
that we saw
in this chapter is just the beginning
deku's ability to quickly mix his six
different quirks in battle
is already pretty amazing and as he
masters all of these quirks his fighting
strategy is just gonna get even more
interesting
and intricate in the future and of
course once he unlocks the final quirk
there's no telling what he will be
capable of just imagine deku with
all seven quirks fully mastered fighting
against
shigaraki and or all for one with like
who knows how many quirks
going all out just imagine all of those
different quirks mixing together and
creating
unbelievable combinations that is going
to be an absolutely
epic final showdown and everything we're
seeing right now
is just a prelude to that future
craziness
let me know what you guys think is our
girl lady nagant still alive
and is she going to pull through also
how did all for one manage to blow her
up in the first place
and is he about to make his move on deku
now or is he going to sit back and wait
a while
longer finally and this is the most
important question
is overhaul ever going to see his boss
again you guys
i can't stand the suspense of not
knowing when
overhaul will get to see the boss it is
just the biggest cliffhanger ever
and i need to know right now if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more boku no hero not boku no pico
content here on the channel
please leave that like to let me know it
helps a lot and if you're new to anime
out pro or maybe you watch our videos
but you haven't subscribed yet
make this the video do you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting that bell and then selecting the
option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
going to miss a ton of our videos even
if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at animeopror
a big thank you to all of our anime
outro patrons for making videos like
this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma and red
haired raven
these guys are absolute mad lads and
disciples
of lord twego himself and i can't forget
all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above
all other clans including ingrata pate
heffa
algital dr cortman the toasted chi ry
carlo
slick back emperor otaku spidey life
chanel tungsten tarkis baked buddhist
and cody hebert
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
angel cruz anatoly kazatsky cricket xp
very gucci alicia octor bonnie park
sinokami and water 10 no ted
isparky65 joanne garcia fat boy games
metal mama corey mcgowan deadly saint
soul ray slice and dice and
pillow if you enjoy our videos and you
feel that they provide value to you
consider supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patreon exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you